how do you feel when you have a
conversation with somebody that can
recite something you told them a year
two years three years ago you're saying
to yourself how does this person even
remember the details of what we talked
about two years ago and the most
important question is how do you feel
when someone can actually do that do you
sit there like the person more
respectable because they're actually
paying attention to what you're saying
so Mario asked me this question
yesterday Mario said hey Pat is there a
way we can talk about how to retain
information that entrepreneurs can
benefit benefit from and you know we
grab the paper and pen we came up with a
12 different things that I'll talk about
here in this video how you can improve
your memory and I'm not talking about
you know the gifted people who have
photographic memory or you know AIA
Dedic memory I'm not talking about that
I'm not talking about you know a Nikola
Tesla what an incredible memory or you
know Teddy Roosevelt that could read the
paper and he can recite the entire thing
back to you that's a certain gift that a
human being has write certain people
have that I'm talking basic things that
you can do to improve your memory that
can help you out in many parts of your
life whether it's business whether it's
relationship whether it's any type of
thing that you're doing that has to do
with people so let's get right into it
number one so when you do retain
information there's a couple things you
got to keep on mind the first thing is
this so think about information that you
yourself remember okay think about
information you yourself that remember
whatever that information may be then
ask the question why do you remember
that okay so stay here why do you
typically two reasons why do you
remember that information for instance
some people can remember sports stats
like this some people can remember a
quote from a president like this some
people can remember mathematical
formulas like this but some people can
remember some bad times on what happened
with details
some people can remember certain law or
speeding limit how do you remember that
how is that possible how do you remember
how do you recall those types of things
so our brain typically the general side
we remember and retain information that
interests us or information that affects
us for instance you will know your tax
rate if it's affect you after paying
sixty three thousand dollars in taxes in
a year hypothetically that affects you
you don't even you're not interested in
it but it affects you okay and so you
know that number or you have an interest
in a video game and you remember certain
secrets to video game they need to do
this because it interests you okay
so what does that have to do with
improving information well when you are
talking to somebody and you want to
retain the information you got to make
sure you're either interested in the
human being or the content or whatever
book you're reading or videos you're
studying or classroom you're studying or
you got to know it's some content that
affects you if it's not one of those two
things you're generally not going to
remember that content for too long let
me give you the second one here the
second one is repetition repetition
could be the way we remember songs okay
like you know I have a certain song I
like and I listen to it over and over
and over again and all of a sudden I
know the lyrics to it right whatever the
lyrics are the same way you and I can
remember certain lyrics to song is the
same way you and I can remember a verse
to a book or a formula or a what a quote
or whatever it is or an event or details
of what a person said because you keep
repeating it and then it stays you keep
repeating and in this age so for
instance today I talk to this this this
this is he said this he said this he
said that's and she said this at the
thought that you're repeating it and he
said this his name is this his name is
this his name is this is repeat repeat
repeat repeat repeat and in your link
you link you link your link so repeat
link repeat link repeat link and then it
stays okay so that's the second thing
the third thing this is the third thing
I like to do let's just say you'll learn
something just now you read something
you're ordered what do you do about it
debate it with a group of two or three
friends or family members what do I mean
by debate for instance what could be the
debate okay you just learned that
unemployment rates in Panama are 2.3
percent you just learned that today
you're going to sit there with like to
say Mariana Paul nine
say hey why do you think Panama's
unemployment rate is 2.3 percent Paul
gives his opinion mari gives his opinion
I give my opinion I disagree no I agree
no I disagree no it's because it is no
it's because of that then we may do a
little bit of research then all of a
sudden that 2.3 percent stays in the
mind okay because you debated it okay
and I'm talking debate with people that
are not combative there are people that
just want to win everything debate
because you're trying to learn so take
whatever you learned debate it does this
work No boom boom boom boom it's going
to stay because there's a lot of energy
you have to use to justify why you
believe that and you have to think about
why and it stays the information stays
fourth point I'm going to tell you about
fourth point share it with other people
so let's just say you read uh-uh you
watch the video and one of the videos is
you know people ask for what type of
mentors you should have and I said T
theory so what is a t theory T stands
for what theory East stands for
experience a stands for application for
instance right so when you want to have
a mentor there's three different levels
of mentors or people that just are
theory like a teacher who's read a lot
of books that are going to give you
their theories that they've read and
their own theories second type of mentor
could be a personalized experience they
work with closely with Michael Jordan
and they know Michael Jordan's habit so
they can tell you what Mike's like this
well Mike's like that or presidents like
this or this CEO was like this great and
the third one is a person you actually
get mentored by Michael Jordan because
they're applying what they know that
they're sharing with you and the best
type of mentor is a trifecta right okay
let's take that subject that you and I
just shared it's one of my videos that
I've done how to choose the right mentor
right okay now take that and share it
with a handful of people today hey you
know what's the best type of mentors
tablet app T what does that mean let me
explain to you T stands for theory
experiment and application so let me
explain what I mean by the Papapa Papapa
Papapa that personal learned it you're
teaching you're sharing that personal
learning mari did you know what a t3t
theory is no I don't let me explain to
with T three theories with mentors Boom
Boom Boom tears for theory is for
experiment a is for application i watch
this I've done that three times to you
okay if
I were to ask you to repeat to me where
T stands I'm willing to bet you know
exactly what it stands for okay
watch go ahead and do it go ahead and do
it I'm gonna give you five seconds what
is T stand for t e that's right theory
experiment application you just did it
why I'm sharing it with you okay
I'm sharing it with you so if you want
to retain the content that you're
learning here today make notes of it go
share it with somebody else it'll
include increase the likelihood of you
retaining the information in this video
fifth point teach on it don't just share
a teach on it so for instance teach on
earth is this and he was explaining to
how that that that that that and there
is this and there's that is different
than sharing because Sharon could be did
you know Michael Jordan shot 55% from
the field no I didn't know that did you
know Michael Jordan one season average
3.8 steals a game I didn't know that did
you know Michael Jordan one sees an
average eight point eight rebounds again
I didn't know that did you know Michael
Jordan almost once he's an average
triple-double I didn't know that yeah
you know a natural double what he call
it is that what it is it's you know
that's a triple-double like Oscar
Robertson I didn't know that do you know
the Ted Williams had two Triple Crowns I
don't know that this is sharing right
but teaching is you know when you're
today I learned when you swing the golf
swing what you got to do is when you're
putting your fingers here and the thumbs
got to be over in this thumb you want to
have it in here and your shoulder if
it's left it goes right and if shoulders
out and your legs you're teaching it
it's different than sharing it that
makes any sense so share teach so share
helps teach ops even more okay both of
them help you retain information let's
get to the next one here okay next one
is linked it to stories whatever you
learn link it to a story it doesn't
matter what it is
link it to stories so if you retain
information and you read a book about
Teddy Roosevelt Roosevelt's first wife
died or first love of his life died I
will link it to the fact that my first
girlfriend that I ever said I love you
to in the army she got into a car
accident passed away I'm linking it it's
emotion it hurts I will remember it you
know you know you could say something
like hey
you know I remember um you know when I
when I learn a certain formula of how to
do a certain workout then I'm gonna link
it to a story of me remembering watching
pumping iron with Arnold Schwarzenegger
on how he was doing this and he told the
story in that video when he's smoking
and he says this distance I will link to
two story so take what you learn link it
to a story then it stays here if it's
linked to a story that's connected to
you not a story that's not connected to
you and as an interesting it doesn't
affect you link your two story
interconnects here I don't know if that
one fully made sense but I think it did
next one is when you're reading a book
okay or you're let's say I'm grabbing
this book I got this gift today from a
Jeff I spoke in our office sales office
a PHP in Boston here and so I'm reading
this book and you know comedian Mike
Donovan used to joke about the Red Sox
tragic playoff history which included
annoying Aaron Boone and it's 11th
inning home run in 2003 ALCS right ok so
then I say man what is ALCS let you see
you're not a baseball fan instead you
skip it and then you go and Papa Papa
but you still don't know what ALCS is
stop find out what ALCS is what is ALCS
then you realize ALCS stands for
American League Championship Series
I believe that's what it stands for now
you know and then you move on even if
you're not a baseball fan stop and do
that because then it sticks the fact
that you took the effort to stop and
want to study that it stays in your mind
if you don't do that it won't stay in
your mind ok next is to to implement
what you learn so if you learned how to
swing the golf swing go implement it and
do it over and over and over again and
then it becomes a part of you you
learned how to give constructive
criticism to somebody and it's 7 steps
ok great write it down and go implement
it today with 3d from different people
and see how you do ok you'll learn how
to shoot a basketball from a pro you
know former NBA player and he told you
when you're shooting you know etc
etcetera mented right away you know from
somebody who's a Olympian swimmer he
tells you how to swim in he's going to
increase your speed of swimming by 2
seconds whatever
implement a right away so learn
implement right away a lot of times
people learn something in a book and
they learn something and they you know
video they watch or something and they
don't implement they wonder how come
date and retain it because you got to
implement it immediately and the sooner
you implement it the more it sticks next
and this one's going to be kind of
strange but it'll make sense to you once
I explain it energy and stamina it
requires energy and stamina to retain
information so if your body is gaining
too much weight and you're tired your
body doesn't have the energy and the
stamina to retain that information to
retain information requires your body to
have the energy to retain it if it
doesn't have it it's not going to retain
it come on
pad you're telling me my weight has to
do with retaining information yes it
does yes it does because retaining
information requires an effort and
anytime you need to take an effort to do
anything it's going to deplete what
energy and if you don't have the energy
in your mind it just says I don't have
any interest to want to retain this
information because I'm tired and I
don't have stamina and my energy is low
that's why energy is a very very
important game and it's not just about
money energy is not just about looks and
looking pretty and looking this and
exercising because I want to look at
exercising when were younger was a
four-hole different purpose when you're
married with kids and later on your new
dog you're exercising for a whole
different reason focus energy stamina
sharper mind okay so the next point
within that will be this if you're if
you're studying a subject and you want
to retain information focus on that
subject if you study five six seven
eight different subjects at the same
time your brain is getting confused
focus on a subject and study that
subject let me explain to what I mean by
this ok so a lot of times a lot of times
you know people who don't know how to
workout they'll go out there and they'll
think that if I work out eight hours in
a day I'm going to build more muscles
right you won't work out is the good two
hour workout is good for you but your
muscles are really growing when you rest
because you tear your muscles and then
you
and then it grows you tear your muscles
and then it grows right okay and you
can't hit every single body part
together on the same day bicep chest not
that one muscle at a time you want to
retain information one subject at a time
one subject at a time take the subject
obsess yourself over it then you retain
the information and if your brain is
exuding too much informant too much
energy because you're you're you're
you're using it way too many different
subjects and it's not retaining because
it's clutter it's all over the place
focus energy into one subject okay next
point next point um oh I got two more
points done in what number 11 next so
the next one is focused attention focus
attention so meaning Mari and I are
talking right now and I asked Mari and I
say Mario's so foreign some things I can
tell you by Mario I can tell you Mari
about the fact that he's a very good
soccer player I can tell the fact that
Mario the way he raises his two
daughters and what things he does and
how he speaks to them and what he
expects from them and how certain
mannerisms and when they come to the
office and what type of homework he
wants him to do I can tell you about
Mario um you know relationship with his
family his brother did you know stories
about his brother military when he went
to visit his brother why you went to New
Mexico and how it was in the drive and
when he went when he speaks I'm focused
attention on him I want to know what
he's saying I am interested I'm
interested and I want to have my focused
attention to him a lot of times people
don't don't pay attention focused
attention to somebody when they're
speaking and they wonder why you did not
retain the information of what they said
okay and all of us are guilty of this
ain't nobody that's perfect there's a
teacher speaking you're distracted then
you're not retaining it it's got to be
focused attention focused attention
focused attention and today we have the
biggest distraction is this you keep
wanting to check Facebook do you keep on
in church or social media you lost seven
seconds you just lost the point that
person was making right right now some
of you guys watching this video you got
distracted because you just did
something else focus the tension focus
the tension and our last point I'll give
you is this this is my favorite one
so right now we went and we spoke in
Boston it's about an hour away from here
we're in Cambridge Rena were parked in a
Harvard parking lot Harvard Business
School side parking lot so we went over
there and as we were making notes and
I'm going through my point after point
after point of what to talk about on
this video at the end I added the last
three or four points and Mario said what
else can we do to retain information I
said here's what I want you to do right
now I said I want you to tell me ten
different things you remember from
tonight's meeting that we had so what do
you mean ten different things ten
different things so Paul was quite Mario
was quite all of a sudden Paul said the
guy who was in the military was an 88
Mike okay the other guy was 23 years old
who asked him about what he wanted as a
girl and he said he wants her to be very
intelligent he wanted to be extremely
attractive he want her to be relaxing
relax about some word he you know was
kind of a tough when you used the word
and then what else did he say about her
a beauty personality personality
attractive
he used that twice and then he said a
relaxing okay then I said what else he
says well the other guy's name was
Keegan I said what else you know Jeff
said that they have to you know grow it
by four times I said what else
well that one girl she said she said
people in Boston are skeptical they
don't trust okay what else so we kept
going going after the in this ten all of
sudden became twenty they came out you
guys came up with like 20-plus different
facts I don't even think was Tony I
think it may have been thirty different
facts that you came up with right names
all these other things that came up why
that right there we worked out not
knowingly that's a workout so the next
time you have a meeting with somebody
the moment you walk away start asking
yourself ten different facts you can
remember from the meeting and mark my
word you will be blown away by how much
more information you retain with that
simple subtle exercise
that simple subtle exercise for you to
do information goes to a whole different
level
and it becomes fun to do that and let me
tell your people around you will
appreciate it and your family's going to
appreciate it people that do business
with you will appreciate you'll have an
edge over your competition who is not
retaining information because they're
not exercised in its area because
they're telling themselves people who
have great memory or either very you
know photographic memory or their
identic you know and they have this and
because of that they have great memory
and that's us I'm not any Cola test I
can't have a better memory while you are
going to go through the 12 notes again
12 points again and you're going to
study it and you're going to implement
in all of them next month two months
three months six months five months
you're going to see difference in your
business and people gonna see what
happened it's called you apply the
things that you learned in this video
okay so with that being said any
questions or thoughts you got comment on
the bottom again if you haven't seen
this video on a complete different
website you can always go back to
Patrick video be calm in one ringtone
your phone we got it and then obviously
we are super close to a hundred thousand
subs make sure to please subscribe to
this channel I simply do this because
you're learning and I love all the
emails that I get the thousands of
emails that I get every single week the
you know fan letters that we get at the
home office that you send and the gifts
and all that other stuff regularly we
get my energy to want to create this
content is because I have students like
you who actually want to study these
videos I'm starting to see a lot of
videos being sent where people writing
all these notes on their walls somebody
tagged me on Instagram where he went and
changed his entire office and he put
white what'd he call him when he can
write it on the wall with a marker he
put the tape he put the tape on it he
can write it he he did his entire big
office like that and he watches every
single video and he writes all the notes
on his wall to be a student that may
sound a little too obsessive to you but
you need to make a value tainment folder
and start taking notes of what you're
learning in this book and there's a
channel here but with that being said
again I applaud those of you that don't
just watch these videos but you study
the content that we have here I have a
very very very big initiative that I'd
be launching which I presented here in
Harvard I'll be launching that
goal is January first latest first
quarter stay tuned I am NOT going to
give you an earlier date we may get it
done earlier it will be very very
massive it's an international project
that affects everybody around the world
who has any aspirations or desires to be
an entrepreneur so stay tuned for that
I'm excited about the project I'm
putting together for all the
entrepreneurs around the world which
when we announced it the value tainment
group has becoming a very very big group
around the world I'm starting to see
people we're in the I am and
entrepreneurship from all over the world
so you know the point I'm making to you
is I'm excited with the fact that you
have made an effort to become a very
good student by studying all these
content nothing excites me more than I
get a message saying Patrick Allen fall
on your counter for the last year mine
come one from 6,000 dollars one to
ninety three thousand dollars a month I
love that there's nothing more exciting
when I get a message from a 13 year old
kid saying I watch your videos in the
last two months I've made $6,000 I love
those stories and those stories are a
byproduct of students who implement the
content that they're learning on this
video with that being said thank you so
much for watching the content take care
everybody goodbye
you